[Musique]
sur ce bassin de be il ya eu énormément
de facteurs d'instruments qui sont
installés et d'artisans autour de la
facture d'instruments et donc la facture
instrumentale donc ça c'est s'est
développée à partir du 19ème siècle
saviola faire un festival sur le lieu de
la création d'instruments
c'est important pour nous pour les
musiciens et on l'espère pour le public
[Musique]
on n'est pas sur un festival de jazz on
n'est pas sur un festival de musiques
actuelles on est vraiment un festival de
musique puisque on mélange musiques
actuelles jazz n 16 est classique et
parfois même sur le même concert avec
des rencontres assez incroyable on a la
chance d'avoir trois créations dans le
cadre de son festival donc évidemment
nathalie defert avec le duc la kespa le
vendredi on aura aussi jacob desvarieux
ses amis et les musiques au pays
le même samedi et on aura également une
création de clémentine de couture qui
est une chanteuse de 2,2 d'opéra et de
musique classique